[Musique]
les diamants font depuis longtemps la
renommée de l'afrique du sud sa richesse
ou six
pour des poignets de kara des hommes
sont prêts à tout à déplacer les
montagnes mais aussi à chasser un peuple
de sa terre
[Musique]
depuis près d'un siècle les blancs
d'afrique du sud ont expulsé les noirs
et les métis pour exploiter les diamants
trouvaient dans la région militaire
en
1994 la fin du régime de l'apartheid
redonne espoir à ceux qui ont tout perdu
clame désormais les terres de leurs
ancêtres et les mines installés dessus
wilhem digue art mène ce combat depuis
plus de dix ans
dans minecraft les mines étaient le
secteur le système de l'apartheid était
le plus fort
c'est les blancs qui peut céder les
mines et pour eux seul saut ya alors oui
la restitution de la mine va nous
redonner notre dignité
nous sommes prêts à travailler dur à
travailler ensemble pour montrer au
monde que nous pouvons réussir
[Musique]
e
la région du riche de velde se trouve au
nord ouest de l'afrique du sud le long
de la côte atlantique
lorsque des diamants ils sont découverts
en 1927 l'état confisqué une grande
partie des terres aux populations qui
vivent sur place
des mines sont créés une des plus
anciennes et celle d' alex corps
sur un territoire grand comme un
département français la zone a été
entièrement sécurisé
seuls les employés ont le droit de
pénétrer toutes les entrées et sorties
sont contrôlés
une route longe la clôture il est pas
trop y sont fréquentes
ce col klein le directeur de la mine
est un ancien policier spécialisé dans
la lutte contre le trafic de diamants
chaque jour ils parcourent des centaines
de kilomètres pour surveiller
l'exploitation des diamants qui se fait
ici à ciel ouvert
laminé large d'environ 10 kilomètres
et elle se prolonge jusqu'à porno
l'autre se trouve à 110 km plus au sud
je fais en sorte d'être présent tous les
jours sur la mine
ma préoccupation principale est de
garder une main de fer sur la production
à la sa ble ment des hommes et des
femmes creuse retourne les roches et le
sable à la recherche des pierres
précieuses
depuis que la mine est ouverte des
millions de carats ont ainsi été
extraites de ses entrailles
une fortune qui a constitué pendant
plusieurs années un trésor pour l'état
sud africain
dans la mine pas un endroit n'échappe
aux contrôles
bonjour crise comment vas tu
tout se passe bien
quand il y a eu des vols c'est souvent
des gens qui ont réussi à pénétrer dans
la mine par la route goudronnée
dans le passé certains ont utilisé des
pigeons pour faire sortir des diamants
d'autres utilisent des équipements qui
sont introduits dans la mine pour des
réparations
ils essaient de cacher des diamants dans
ses équipements pour les faire ensuite
sortir de la mine
[Musique]
chaque jour tous les employés d' alex
corps pasto détecteur la mine ne lésine
pas avec la sécurité un simple diamant
d'un carat se vend plusieurs milliers
d'euros
une fois taillé et poli est sorti il
vaudra plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros
tentation rêve désir
le diamant provoque toujours les mêmes
effets pour l'éternité
et quel est le prix indique 2 millions
de rands
négociable tout est toujours négociable
et celui-ci de taille moyenne il est
beaucoup plus cher que les deux autres
c'est un diamant de 5 carats de couleurs
il coûte 2,2 millions
ce diamant superbe ça je trouve le prix
raisonnable compte tenu de sa taille
il coûte combien je crois qu'il serait 2
millions 2,2 millions d'euros
deux millions deux oeuvres de sarah
stern bon je vais l'acheter pour une
très jolie femme
c'est pour ma fiancée
la gamme de prix est très large cela va
de 10000 rendent à 2,2 millions de rands
220000 euros toutes les femmes rêvent
d'avoir un diamant qu'il soit gros petit
c'est une expérience intime les
spéciales d'en posséder un on a des
clients très différents certains
pointent du doigt un diamant dans la
vitrine et disent je veux celui là il ne
demande même pas le queens à tête avec
d'autres clients vous devez vous asseoir
avec eux pendant longtemps pour leur
expliquer les spécificités et la valeur
d'un diamant et aussi la valeur qu'il
aura plus tard
[Musique]
avant de briller de mille feux dans les
devantures des plus belles bijouterie du
monde les diamants ont fait un long
périple
certains d'entre eux proviennent d' alex
corps
au milieu des tonnes de gravier déversés
à l' usine de traitement le centre
névralgique de la mine les diamants
bruts vont enfin apparaître
comme ronald coquerel une centaines de
prospecteurs et leurs équipes
travaillent qui si ils ont reçu une
licence d'exploitation de la part de
l'état sud africain à qu'ils reversent
une partie de leurs trouvailles
[Musique]
je suis ravi d'avoir trouvé une pierre
comme celle-là
je crois qu'elle doit faire à peu près 3
carats
c'est une pierre superbe
les pierres sont récupérés par le
contremaître de la mine pour être posé
elles seront ensuite vendus par alex
corps
pour celles qui font plus de 6 carats la
recette est partagé entre la mine et le
prospecteur qui les a trouvées pour les
autres la vente est groupé et le
bénéfice mutualisé entre tous les
chercheurs de diamants de la
mi-mars à 3
min sortie ça dit pierre qui font dix
neuf trois quarts à caton une de 6
carats et deux de quatre carats
c'est une très bonne moyenne
la mine d'alex corvette très contente
ils vont prendre 52 % pour eux
tout le monde peut être content
l'exploitant la direction et même les
gens de la sécurité
prenait là de quoi se réjouir un simple
diamant brut de 3 carats vaut plusieurs
milliers d'euros
pas une de ces pierres ne quitte la mine
sans avoir été répertoriés et classés
par ce coq lingue le directeur de la
mine
entre ses mains passent un véritable
trésor
d'autant que les diamants d' alex corps
sont réputés de très belle qualité
[Musique]
la valeur d'un diamant est caractérisée
par les quatre c'est kara coupe couleur
et clarté c'est ça qui détermine sa
valeur
celui ci c'est un très beau diamant
c'est un octogone
c'est une pierre très recherchés car
elle est facile à taez il y aura peu de
déchets dans sa taille parking d'un
strapontin
on doit pouvoir obtenir pour une pierre
comme celle ci à peu près 2000 dollars
par carat et elle doit faire à peu près
10 carats
chaque mois ce coq langue transporte
lui-même vers johannesburg toute la
production d' alex corps afin de limiter
les risques de braquage bien réelle
malgré les précautions l'heure du départ
est tenue secrète jusqu'au dernier
moment
[Musique]
dans la mallette de ce colloque
plusieurs millions d'euros en diamants
un petit bimoteur est affrété les
autorités de la mine il permet de
rejoindre johannesburg la capitale
économique du pays située à plus de 1200
km
à johannesburg l'insécurité n'est pas un
mythe
agressions vols enlèvements ce côté sa
mallette constitue une cible potentielle
de choix le trajet de l'aéroport au
centre-ville s'effectue sous haute
protection mais bon
ici à johannesbourg les gens fous tu
pourras rien c'est extrêmement dangereux
de se promener en possession de diamants
si comme moi vous avez un sac rempli de
viande et voleurs peuvent vous
l'arracher en un rien de temps et
disparaître avec votre production du
mois
ici j'organise pour le convoyage des
diamants une sécurité de très haut
niveau
il ya dans cette ville de nombreux
enlèvements
il faut vraiment rester aux aguets
ce colloque ne baissera lagarde que
lorsque sa précieuse cargaison sera
enfin livré et sécurisé à la bourse du
diamant au coeur du quartier d'affaires
de johannesburg
c'est ici que les diamantaires d'anvers
de tel-aviv et de new york viennent se
fournir
pour optimiser la valeur des diamants
sud africain le gouvernement encourage
depuis 40 ans la création d'ateliers de
taille une approche nouvelle pour un
continent tous les matières premières
sont généralement exporté bruts non
transformés
un des plus gros clients de la mine
d'alex corps et le groupe international
d'origine israélienne jusqu'à y met son
directeur aux rites emeline est un
orfèvre en matière de diamants
vous l'envoyer au laser pour le couper
en deux
pour en faire un modèle rond
ce diamant vient d' alex corps but
lapierre faisait 24 carats de une fois
scindée en deux et taille et on
obtiendra un diamant poli il fera 5
carats
en général les diamants d'alex corps
sont de très belles qualités
c'est très facile et très agréable de
travailler de telle pierre
[Musique]
lorsque vous achetez un diamant brut
vous êtes plein de rêves et d'illusions
chacun y voit des solutions différentes
car le tailler côté des couleurs et des
qualités variés
donc si vous me demandez combien de
valeur je vais y ajouter vraiment
difficile de répondre à cette question
parfois même on peut perdre de l'argent
on a jamais aucune garantie qu'une fois
taillé vous ayez gagné de l'argent
c'est un jeu très risqué
c'est intéressant de constater qu'avec
l'expérience
après avoir observé de nombreux diamants
pendant longtemps
il y a quelque chose qui se passe et que
je ne peux pas expliquer comme si
quelque chose se déclencher dans le
cerveau dès que je soulève un diamant et
que je le regarde je sais immédiatement
le modèle exact il faut tailler c'est
comme si mes doigts m'indiquer la taille
maximum que l'on peut en tirer
après avoir analysé la pierre décider du
choix du modèle et de la coupe la ligne
de ses yeux qui sépare le diamant en
deux et tracés au stylo feutre c'est
seulement après que l'ordinateur est
utilisé pour confirmer les options et
calculer le prix de vente en fonction
des cours du marché international
[Musique]
steinmetz est connu pour son travail sur
les gros diamant un travail de haute
précision
la taille est entièrement réalisé à la
main et à l'oeil elle peut facilement
durer plusieurs mois
un savoir faire extraordinaire qui va
permettre de multiplier le prix
les diamants seront ensuite vendus aux
plus prestigieux bijoutier des états
unis d'europe et des pays du golfe
[Musique]
la taille du diamant en afrique du sud
ne commence qu'en 1970
mais son exploitation des buts un siècle
plus tôt
à kimberley en plein centre du pays
en 1927 des diamants sont trouvés alex
corps le long de la côte atlantique
rapidement des mineurs a cours dans
l'espoir de faire fortune
pour éviter une ruée qui ferait chuter
les cours l'état sud-africain décide de
nationaliser la mine il entend contrôler
le marché et encaisser les profits
[Musique]
les noirs et les métis ont relégué au
simple travail de manoeuvre d'ailleurs
aucune photo officielle de la mine
d'alex corps me retient leur
contribution pourtant essentiel le titre
de mineurs n'est octroyée aux seuls
blancs
[Musique]
les diamants d'alex corps se trouvent
sur les terres des namas des bergers
nomades qu'ils ont été chassés par la
mine
ils ont dû se retrancher loin de la mer
dans les montagnes reculées et aride
aujourd'hui seule une trentaine d'entre
eux réussi encore à vivre de l'élevage
le mieux serait de changer de campements
de monter plus au nord
tétouan le chien
il est important que les bergers
préservent leur style de vie parce que
c'est par la culture que l'on reconnaît
un peuple ces gens qui continuent de
vivre selon les habitudes pastorale des
namas ce sont deux vrais nama
[Musique]
en perdant leurs pâturages les bergers
en dut se sédentariser dans des lieux
isolés comme ici à kubus un des
principaux villages de la communauté
nama
[Musique]
vous voyez il n'y a pas de développement
de magasins de structures médicales même
pas d'eau courante
les mines sont venus l on extrait des
diamants les ont vendus loin d'ici
et notre communauté n'en a tiré aucun
bénéfice
elle n'a pas pu se développer
l'apartheid était une très mauvaise
chose
à kubus il n'y a pas d'école pas de
travail non plus les seuls sont pas
disponibles sont ceux de manoeuvre dans
les mines de la région les emplois
souvent mal payé un grand andré seger
ton longtemps travaillé à l'export ils
en ont gardé des souvenirs bien amer
rappelle-toi les blancs avaient droit du
pain blanc et du sucre blanc
mais pour nous c'était pas noir a6 g
sucre brun
un
homme blanc marié recevrait 250 rands
est un célibataire blanc 225 monde
non les 250 30 c'était pour un
célibataire blanc pas pour un homme
blanc marié
ah oui oui c'est vrai donc un
célibataire blanc chez 250 rands alors
qu'un célibataire mais ça ne touchait
que 25 randy foye - et à célibataire
noir 15 30 seulement
nos parents ne parlait pas afrique ans
il parlait principalement leur langue le
nam à modeler même
s'il n'avait pas le droit de parler nama
en public par lorsqu'il était en
présence des blancs
une cause parce que les blancs pensait
que les namas les calomniait
ils pensaient aussi qu'on organisait des
plans pour voler les diamants
et si tu n'étais pas d'accord avec ces
conditions il te licencier sur-le-champ
arcanes de chasser comme un chien à
ypres
la mine a chassé les gens de leurs
terres elle a aussi cassé les structures
familiales
éloignés de chez eux pendant de longs
mois les hommes ont abandonné femme ses
enfants restés vivre dans leur village à
des dizaines de kilomètres de là
alors je trouve insupportable
tout ce que l'on a dû endurer
paumé à l'onu je ne comprends pas on est
plus les traités de la sorte
elle ce n'est pas humain ils ont été
traités de cette manière et pourtant ils
ont survécu par dieu mercier ont survécu
[Musique]
pendant des années les namas sont
déplacés spoliés humiliés sur leur terre
la mine d'alex corps construit une ville
pour les prospecteurs blanc alexander b
à l'époque de l'apartheid ils vivent à
huis clos rugby tennis piscine golf tout
est réservé à la population blanche
ce petit oasis de verdure est conforme
aux lois de ségrégation raciale
l'accès est strictement interdit aux
noirs et aux métis
c'est une des églises d'alexander b
c'est l'église africaine
hommes mes deux enfants ont été baptisés
dans cette église et moi aussi
l'avis de ronald coquerelles et
entièrement lié au diamant d' alex corps
elle est née alexander bay est comme son
père elle a construit toute sa carrière
à la mine
rooney lui a même rencontré son mari lui
aussi mineur
à cette époque tous ceux qui avaient
besoin de travailler et qui recherchait
le confort et la sécurité de l'emploi
venez habiter alexander la mine d'alex
corps était une bonne entreprise les
gens voulaient venir travailler pour
cette compagnie d'état elle s'occupait
très bien de ses employés le logement et
les soins étaient gratuits tout le monde
voulait venir à alexander bay dans la
région à l'export c'était le pain et le
beurre des gens c'était la compagnie de
la compagnie la mine d'alex corps est
alors à l'image de la politique
coloniale du pays tout entier mieux la
captation des terres riches ce fléau
seule bd fil des bleus les autres
catégories noirs métis indiens sont
exclues et envoyé sur des terres sans
ressources
là
[Musique]
avec la mise en place du régime de
l'apartheid en 1948 le système de
ségrégation et renforcer le pays est
divisé en zones raciale qui doivent être
strictement respectées
des listes sont établis des populations
entières déplacés c'est ainsi que 200
familles métis arrive dans la région où
sont parqués les namas dire qui alors
quatre ans l'histoire de sa famille est
singulière son grand père blanc refuse
d'abandonner son épouse métis toute la
famille devient alors métis au regard de
la loi sud-africaine
là c'est mon grand père qui
se tient debout sur ma droite
je me souviens quand l'officier est venu
faire le recensement
il a demandé à mon grand père vous devez
me dire ce que je dois écrire sur votre
fiche vous êtes blanc mais si vous êtes
blanc vous ne pouvez pas vous installé
dans le riche terrasse failed si vous
êtes blanc vous devez rester où vous
êtes
alors mon grand père a dit je ne peux
pas rester
je dois aller dans leur richterswil zh
avec mon épouse
alors vous devez me classifiés comme
métis
quand il est devenu métis mon père est
devenu métis ma mère est devenue métis
et moi aussi je suis devenu métier
les lois raciales vont déchirer les
familles paupérisée la grande majorité
de la population et surtout limiter le
destin de ceux qui ne sont pas blancs
[Musique]
si on voulait devenir électricien ou
doctor who ce type de métier
on nous disait que l'on n'avait pas le
droit
parce qu'on était métis on pouvait
simplement devenir instituteur ou à leur
malheur
cela rendait la vie très difficile
et c'est seulement quand on quitte l
école et le village qu'on réalisait ce
qu'était l'apartheid
il y avait trois mondes
le monde des noirs le monde des métis et
le monde des blancs
[Musique]
1994 sonne le glas du système de
l'apartheid nelson mandela est élu
président de l'afrique du sud après
avoir passé 27 ans en prison
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir du plus vieux
prisonnier politique du monde un vent de
changement radical souffle sur le pays
nous allons de l'avant
et la marche
vers la liberté et la justice
c'est irréversible
animaux
un médecin
[Applaudissements]
les anciennes minorité spoliés par
l'apartheid relève la tête et demande
réparation
pour wilhem du gart c'est le début d'un
long combat
originaire du rift oswalt cet ancien
mineur d' alex corps va devenir le
leader de la demande de restitution des
terres riche en diamants
une bataille longue et difficile qui
passe par un procès retentissant à la
cour constitutionnelle de johannesburg
cette nouvelle cour est bâti sur l'une
des anciennes prisons de nelson mandela
elle a pour objectif de défendre les
droits de tous les sud africains quelle
que soit la couleur de leur peau
elle a aidé ville m dans sa lutte contre
la mine d' alex corps
pourquoi dit elle là vous avez
nécessairement des la
cellule artisans laliberté
s'est battu pour le peuple d'afrique du
sud et il est devenu l'icône rude
mondiale de la liberté
ici c'est mon héros
il est pour moi une source d'inspiration
quotidienne pour essayer de faire
changer les choses
[Musique]
c'est en 1998 que vilain mais son peuple
demande la restitution d'une partie des
terres de la région dont celle de la
mine d'alex corps en 2001 ils sont
déboutés il engage alors une procédure
auprès de la cour constitutionnelle
en 2004 elle leur donnera finalement
raison face à l'état sud africain
les terres et la mine d'alex corps sont
désormais propriété de ceux qui en
avaient été chassés
les compensations financières sont aussi
demandé en guise d'indemnisation elles
ne seront obtenu que trois ans plus tard
comme vous pouvez le voir ce fut une
très longue bataille je dois relire des
documents encore le rafraîchir la
mémoire
la toute dernière étape de la bataille
juridique s'est passé à la cour d'appel
du cap
le 9 octobre 2007
comme beaucoup de gens de notre
communauté était venu au gabon pour cela
et on a assisté pendant deux jours aux
séances et un jugement final
jam trail de neige
on était tous ou de joie
j'avais des larmes plein les yeux
lorsque je suis sortie du tribunal
c'était des larmes de bonheur quoi les
larmes de colère
cette victoire exemplaire est
aujourd'hui évoqués sur les murs du
grand hall de la cour constitutionnelle
tout le monde sait que c'est un des cas
de restitution les plus importants en
afrique du sud mais aussi dans le monde
entier
les riches sur les leaders sont
satisfaits mais ils se sont battus
durement pour récupérer leurs terres
alors on est très fier d'être un des
quatre cas qui sont mentionnés par la
cour constitutionnelle au pôle et et on
espère que d'autres communautés vont
pouvoir s'en inspirer
gagner d'autres batailles pour récupérer
leurs terres
malgré les succès devant les tribunaux
sur le terrain les changements tarde à
venir
il aime pas son temps à sillonner le
pays il veut accélérer la mise en oeuvre
de la restitution de la mine
je voyage beaucoup à travers le pays
pour des réunions avec les actionnaires
les investisseurs des ministres des
partenaires
tous ceux qui peuvent nous aider à
mettre en application la restitution
[Musique]
bonne ce soir il m a rendez vous avec
ses conseillers pour préparer les
dernières négociations avec les
autorités de l'ex corps
alors évidemment comment ça se passe
avec aminé
alex corps continue exploitation li
gagne de l'argent
nous nous mettons l'argent de côté pour
le démarrage de nos activités donc les
choses bougent un peu matters et
maintenant je crois qu'il faut que nous
ayons une réunion avec le conseil
d'administration d' alex corps
mais les procédures sont complexes il
faut vous me donniez les conseils
si dans le riche de welt le processus de
restitution est lent à johannesburg la
situation change plus rapidement pour
les communautés autrefois discriminer
africaine romance est une success story
100% noir 100% diamant
nous pouvons faire à peu près tous les
modèles que vous désirez vous n'avez
qu'à nous dessiner sur papier ce que
vous aimeriez et nous ferons en sorte de
le réaliser mais
africaine romane se fournit auprès d'
alex corps c'est une entreprise
pionnière dans un secteur jusque alors
détenue par les blancs
[Musique]
son fondateur michel moussa a été avocat
comme nelson mandela il a fait partie du
premier gouvernement noir et fut député
pendant dix ans
africaine romance et sa dernière
création
ici c'est le cerveau d'african romance
c'est là que nous planifions les
diamants à partir des pierres brutes
nous décidons la taille des pierres des
décisions qui feront que nous allons
gagner ou à perdre de l'argent
ce département est capital il est dirigé
par sylvia c'est d'être soi n'est noir
la plus expérimentée du pays pour ce
type de travail
les succès de motion moussa sont
multiples 94 % de ses employés sont
noirs métis ou indiens
les capitaux et le sont à 100% les
employés possèdent 7 % des actions un
projet volontariste soutenu par le
gouvernement qui affiche fièrement son
identité africaine
l'afrique se trouve dans une des étapes
les plus prometteuses de son
développement
les africains commencent à prendre en
main leur destin
ils ont enfin réalisé qu'ils ont en leur
possession des ressources de grande
valeur et qu'ils peuvent utiliser ces
ressources d'une manière correcte
dans notre pays nous avons des légendes
comme nelson mandela et d'autres
personnalités qui ont émergé et qui ont
commencé à mettre notre pays dans la
bonne voie
alex corps est un exemple similaire
c'est une ancienne mine d'état qui a été
une mine de l'apartheid
les terres ont été prises aux habitants
pour les exploiter ils ont emporté les
diamants sans re donné quoi que ce soit
aux communautés d'origine
il y encore de nombreux défis à relever
dans le processus de restitution cela ne
marche pas encore parfaitement on
pourrait sans doute encore améliorer
certaines choses admet ce n'est juste
qu'une question de temps
c'est en effet juste une question de
temps mais la route est encore longue
dans le riche 100 autour de l'ex corps
des structures économiques hérités de
l'apartheid sont toujours profondément
inégalitaire les habitants toujours
pauvres pour accélérer le changement le
nouveau pouvoir noir a mis en place des
lois de discrimination positive les
mines de la région doivent investir une
partie de leurs profits dans la
formation dans les négociations où il
fait figure d'habitué wilhem insistent
toujours pour que cet investissement
soit une part non négligeable des
profils
nous on veut 10 % des profits
l'an et métis armes égales autour d'une
même table une situation inimaginable il
ya quinze ans à peine
changement d'ambiance tout aussi radical
alexander b
les noirs et les métis qui était
autrefois proscrit dans la ville ont
enfin le droit d'y habiter
leurs enfants vont maintenant à l'école
avec les blancs et les habitants vivent
à l'heure de la réconciliation
[Musique]
i was left il faut apprendre à vivre
avec le changement il faut faire avec
si les riches torse wenders venir ici il
n'ya pas de problème ce n'est plus notre
ville seulement ce n'est plus uniquement
notre communauté il faut l'accepter
il faut que nous soyons gentils et
accueillants avec les nouveaux habitants
[Musique]
c'est dans cet esprit que rhône elle se
rend au dîner organisé par son église un
dîner auquel participe désormais toutes
les communautés
la nation arc-en-ciel changent mais pas
aussi vite que l'a souhaité nelson
mandela
on a été éduqué comme ça
on a été éduqué avec l'interdiction de
se mélanger
ici c'était une vraie colonie pour les
blancs
c'est ça qui s'est passé
avec les changements politiques que tout
va changer
je pense que les gens vont avoir des
difficultés à s'adapter à ces
changements
cela des deux côtés les gens ici
viennent de cultures très différentes
c'est comme si on les avait soudainement
jeté dans une grande marmite comme celle
qui est là bas le mélange va mettre du
temps à prendre
depuis quelques mois vilain mais les
risques velder ont enfin leur bureau en
ville pour être à pied d'oeuvre à côté
de leur mine
dans le passé nos premiers bureaux
étaient à skis mme fontaine
puis sont allés à kubus
de là nous sommes venus ici sur les
terres qui nous ont été restitués c'est
donc nos nouveaux bureaux et on va les
rénover l'année prochaine pour qu'ils
ressemblent à de vrais bureaux
cette décision a été prise il ya très
longtemps lorsque nous avons gagné le
premier procès m il fallait que l'on
vienne ici alexander b pour qu'ils me
voient ils réalisent que nous étions
désormais les propriétaires de la mienne
wilhem a créé une société de prospection
la rmc sociétés minières des richesses
d'helder il en est le directeur il
espère pouvoir bientôt exploiter les
diamants d' alex corps les négociations
sont en cours il n'a pas encore accès à
la production de la mine mais il reste
néanmoins plein d'espoir
vous voyez l'histoire est en marche dans
le stade
pendant 80 ans nous étions seulement les
employés dorénavant nous sommes les
actionnaires de la nuit mais maintenant
il faut que nous changions notre façon
de penser il faut que nous réalisions
que c'est maintenant les propriétaires
il faut que nous fassions fonctionner la
ligne que nous touchions et la viande il
faut que nous expliquions les carats
pour nous aider à nous développer
c'est cela qui va changer notre vie pour
toujours
pour qu'ils puissent exploiter leurs
diamants les risques velter ont obtenu
de l'état sud-africain la propriété du
terrain les droits miniers sur terre
ainsi que l'équivalent de 14 millions
d'euros en compensation des diamants
extraits depuis 1927
[Musique]
mais les ressources du sous sol sont
largement entamée il y a vingt ans
alex corps s'est tourné vers la mer dont
les fonds regorge aussi de diamant
les mêmes que ceux trouvés sur la côte
aujourd'hui plus de 80% de la production
proviennent de la mer
[Musique]
e
scotland le directeur de la mine
commence ses journées par l'inspection
des unités de production en bord de mer
[Musique]
c'est la seule région au monde où l'on
extrait des diamants des fonds marins
les veines exploité sur terre se
prolonge sous l'eau et elles peuvent
rapporter gros
[Musique]
le plus gros diamant que j'ai trouvé en
mer faisait 42 carats on a aussi trouvé
une pierre de 40 carats et d'autres
pierres plus petit on était très heureux
c'était en plein hiver ce qui n'est pas
vraiment la bonne saison ce jour là on a
gagné beaucoup d'argent
les prises miraculeuse se passe
généralement en pleine mer les réserves
sous-marines s'étale sur plusieurs
kilomètres au large des côtes
c'est en bateau qu'il faut aller
chercher les diamants le petit port
construit sur la mine est très couru les
nouveaux prospecteur de la mer sont
souvent des enfants d'anciens mineurs
dans l'ex corps
les gens qui ont des concessions ici
viennent de la région
de la plupart d'entre eux sont nés
alexander paix et aussi dans le port
d'un côté
et en ce qui concerne les riches heures
zelder à ce qu'ils sont pour l'instant
recruté comme membres d'équipage même si
certains aimeraient bien de venir
prendre
comme clip
grâce aux nouvelles mesures prises par
le gouvernement
certains peuvent maintenant suivre des
formations pour apprendre à plonger
et pouvoir ainsi prendre part aux
activités marine
leur demande de restitution de la mine
étaient légitimes ils l'ont obtenu
maintenant il faut les aider pour qu'on
puisse développer leurs propres
activités de prospection pour leur
propre bénéfice
sans expérience ni capitale la tâche des
risques belder pour exploiter les
diamants en mer est délicate
aujourd'hui il embarque toujours en tant
que simple matelot sur les bateaux des
prospecteurs blanc comme celui de gavin
crawford
le métier de prospecteurs marin exige de
nombreuses compétences
kevin est à la fois navigateur plongeurs
démineurs
ce matin il positionne son embarcation
sur l'emplacement que la mine lui a
octroyé
cette petite flèche c'est le bateau
le gps indique la position exacte du
bateau si on fait descendre ici le
plongeur
il va pouvoir accéder directement à la
veine que l'on voit là
pour atteindre la veine diamantifère le
bateau doit être fermement à maré
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
la mer est souvent agitée et les jours
de temps calme se font plus rares quand
il a commencé kevin sortait en mer plus
de 150 fois par an aujourd'hui il
n'effectue qu'une trentaine de sorties
le temps est au beau fixe il n'y a pas
de vent l'eau éclaire en surface mais
elle peut être trouble plus en
profondeur
on ne sera fixé que lorsque le plongeur
sur un sous l'eau souvent l'eau est
propre en surface mais les deux derniers
mètres peuvent être très salée troubles
on espère que ce ne sera pas le cas
m
van courant visibilité toutes les
conditions semblent aujourd'hui
rassembler mais sous l'eau les risques
demeurent
deux de mes amis sont morts en plongée
un est mort juste là bas
et l'autre est mort dans le port
mais si l'on respecte toutes les
consignes de sécurité et qu'on ne prend
pas de risques alors normalement tout
doit bien se passer
[Musique]
il faut parfois déplacer des blocs
entiers qui obstruent l'accès aux
diamants
la liaison radio mise au point par kevin
est une aide précieuse
elle permet de coordonner les efforts de
l'équipage resté à bord et du plongeur
qui travaille au fond
que la mer viennent à grossir et
l'extraction est immédiatement stoppé
le gravier remonter à bord puis passer
en broyeuse
les cailloux les plus lourds ceux qui
peuvent contenir des diamants sont
conservés en can ils seront triés à
terre
le reste est rejetée à la mer
[Musique]
une extraction est assez difficile
il y à deux mètres de sable
puis de l'argile et le gravier se trouve
juste en dessous la dernière fois on a
trouvé un très beau diamant ici alors on
est plutôt optimiste
mais c'est seulement une fois rentré à
l' usine que l'on pourra savoir si on a
eu de la chance ou non
une heure à peine après le début du
pompage les opérations doivent être
interrompue
il y a eu un incident sous l'eau
[Musique]
j'ai bien peur que l'on doive rentrer au
port maintenant
le tuyau cassé net il faut que l'on
envoie le plongeur récupérer le tuyau
sous l'eau avant de pouvoir rentrer
c'est à cause de la houle qui était trop
forte et qu' à exercer trop de pression
sur le trio
[Musique]
normalement on remplit les cas leurs
abords
les chances de trouver des diamants
augmente de façon exponentielle lorsque
l'on remplit tous les sacs
aujourd'hui on a rempli deux sacs à
peine il en faudrait 10 au minimum
franchement je ne suis pas très
optimiste
on a peut-être eu de la chance et
attraper quelques pierres mais on a
vraiment besoin de gros volumes de
gravier
mais on n'y peut rien des accidents
comme celui ci arrive
de retour à la mine c'est l'heure de
vérité
comme le pressentait kevin la pêche n'a
rien de miraculeux
on
le concentré qui peut contenir des
diamants c'est très décevant on n'a
presque rien obtenu
on n'a pas eu de chance cette fois-ci
j'espère qu'on aura plus de chance la
prochaine fois mais malheureusement pas
cette fois ci
sinon le belize il peut ce n'est pas un
business facile j'ai des amis et des
collègues qui avaient 20 ans
d'expérience et qui ont dû vendre leurs
bateaux et abandonner leur concession
on peut se poser la question suivante si
des gens de ce calibre n'arrive pas à
gagner leur vie avec cette activité cela
va être extrêmement difficile pour
quelqu'un qui n'a aucune expérience de
réussir dans cette industrie
en attendant de pouvoir lui aussi
commencé son travail de prospecteurs
wilhem entend mener à bien la fin de son
combat
il a d'ores et déjà obtenu pour sa
communauté le paiement de dividendes de
la part de la mine d'alex corps celle
annonce qu'il vient faire ce soir
une sacrée revanche son histoire
désormais on se presse pour figurer sur
la liste qu'il fait circuler la liste
des anciens bannis est devenue celle des
heureux élus
[Musique]
l'expérience de la vie c'est plus
précieux que l'argent non
[Musique]
j'ai pas raison voilà nous on a vécu
toute notre vie sans un sou
[Musique]
maintenant vous allez recevoir beaucoup
d'argent réfléchissait à quoi vous allez
l'utiliser bon en attendant il est
important que vous ouvriez un compte
bancaire vous pouvez utiliser n'importe
quelle banque ou même la poste c'est
pour ceux qui ont déjà leur compte en
banque n'oubliez pas d'aller voir joe
alina à la fin de la séance pour lui
donner vos coordonnées
non
épatant
mais comment
alex corps versera chaque 1 200 euros en
guise de premier dividende
une somme dans un pays où le taux de
chômage atteint 40% et où le salaire
dans les campagnes dépasse rarement une
centaine d'euros par mois
je sais d'où je viens et je sais où je
vais dans le passé les richesses werder
étaient ceux qui étaient pauvres qui ne
savaient rien qui étaient à la traîne
même à l'école ce qui venait du riste
welt n'existait pas aux yeux des autres
maintenant tout le monde veut venir dans
notre région
car aujourd'hui elle est sur la carte
autrefois elle était aussi sur la carte
mais personne ne la voyait il ya du
potentiel si alors beaucoup de gens
veulent venir pour visiter ou pour
s'installer
sur sept a causé cet argent de la
restitution
et maintenant les gens veulent devenir
riche de spiders
et heureusement pour moi je suis riche
de gelder est très fier de lui
[Musique]
pour les riches tous velder la victoire
sera complète quand ils pourront enfin
démarrer l'exploitation de la mine
les barbelés qui entourent alex corps ne
disparaîtront pas du paysage
fils-aime espère simplement qu'ils
perdront leur valeur symbolique
qu'ils ne seront plus là pour signifier
ségrégation raciale mais pour assurer la
sécurité des diamants retrouvé de son
peuple
les diamants ne seront pas éternels
on devrait en avoir encore pour dix ans
et si nous nous en occupons bien on
devrait pouvoir exploiter la mine
pendant vingt ans peut-être en comptant
la terre et la mer
mais le plus important c'est de ramener
notre communauté ici et richters elders
puisse se dire maintenant nous sommes
les propriétaires cela va nous rendre
notre dignité on pourra se dire que l'on
est propriétaire des terres dont ont été
chassés nos ancêtres c'est cela qui va
apporter le bonheur à notre communauté